when we started to go after greg's dream
of being a professional longboarder life
changed a lot
you're out with your father you're just
out there having fun like nothing really
beats that like chasing after the same
dream and i think that's the best part
about it for sure
this is mike paprosky he's my father he
does downhill skateboarding along with
street illusion
this is greg paprovsky he's from golden
colorado he's a downhill skateboarder
downhill longboarding is basically going
down the hill as fast as you can
street luge is very similar to
longboarding except you lay down
greg still is the youngest to competed
at the pikes peak downhill race here in
colorado springs the fastest i've gone
to date is 70 miles an hour but that's
that's about it
2011 my
ex and i were going through divorce
it was a big adjustment for greg he was
lashing out physically and having
problems in school
i needed to try to motivate him get him
on the right track i told him if you get
your stuff together in school we can go
after any dream you want to
i decided i want to pursue longboarding
because it put me in the zone and make
me forget about all the negative things
that were happening in my life at the
time
so i bought him a leather suit for
christmas that year and and our first
year on the scene we traveled to canada
new york washington california
we were at the ohio gravity games
we rode the free bus to within five
miles of the event and then we lugged
all of our luggage down there it started
raining on us we had a two-man tent
that's all we had and as we were cuddled
up in that tent with all our gear and
everything
gregory
said to me he goes dad you never told me
the dream was going to be easy
and it it was at that point i knew this
kid's got it he understands like he gets
it just being able to be at the very
lowest with my father and the very
highest we know that we can tough out
anything together and that we can we can
make it
i've seen greg grow a lot since we
started skateboarding a lot of people
look at something and think oh i can't
can't do that
greg looks at it and says how am i gonna
do that
you